efectivamente décima jornada de
manifestación aquí en Francia clave
tanto para el gobierno de Manuel macron
como para los sindicatos a esta hora
aquí en la Plaza de la República el
ambiente es muy tranquilo sin embargo se
espera una manifestación violenta como
la última donde además de aumentar el
número de manifestantes también hubo
mucha quema de basura Aprovechando que
había la huelga de los recolectores de
basura en París y en otras ciudades
justamente se dice que también quienes
marchan zonas más jóvenes y que eso
podría fomentar justamente los actos
violentos sin embargo hay voces desde la
izquierda pero también del Consejo
europeo de los derechos humanos y de la
liga de Derechos Humanos francesas que
acusan al gobierno de violencia excesiva
de hecho el ministro del interior ha
movilizado a 13.000 personas gendarmes y
policías en todo el país para controlar
la situación aquí por ejemplo a la Plaza
de la República Hay un gran perímetro de
seguridad a unos 300 metros de esta
Plaza a la redonda para Evitar que las
personas ingresen con objetos que puedan
servir como proyectiles se realiza una
revisión de las mochilas y de los bolsos
por parte de la policía de lo que es la
parte política los sindicatos siguen
Llamando al gobierno de Manuel macron a
una pausa quien ha tomado la voz es el
líder de las cfdt el sindicato más
conservador y aquí en el gobierno
justamente dirigido sus últimas
propuestas o llamadas de atención en los
últimos días Este líder de este
sindicato ha dicho que ellos pueden
volver a conversar con el gobierno
siempre que se suspenda este proyecto Y
hoy ha pedido que haya un mediador el
gobierno a través de su portavoz ha
dicho que no se necesita un mediador sin
embargo se muestra al menos abierto a
conversar con los sindicatos la primera
ministra Elizabeth Ball prometía ayer
que nunca más presentarán un 49 3 es
decir aprobarán un proyecto de ley por
decreto excepto los temas financieros y
que la idea es reunirse durante tres
semanas con los alcaldes con los
diputados pero también con los
sindicatos que lo deseen para analizar
los temas de los futuros proyectos de
ley y que estos lleguen al parlamento ya
bien discutidos y conversados creando
consensos